they are really big into social media
and youtubing and cont do you have any
advice for them the hardest thing is
when you're a kid when you're making
this content is not getting traction
people want to give up like when you
make a video and it gets two views it
feels shitty but the reality is
everybody started at two views Mr Beast
got two views that's how it starts and
so like I did videos in this store when
YouTube first came out in 2006 for
months and months and months and got no
views 80 60 40 but if you love the
videos you're making and you're talking
about [__] that you're interested in
then you're just loving the making of
the video and then the results will come
a year or two later so you do it because
you want to make the videos not because
you want the subscribers or the fame